citizens of the reject Nation we are
here for the Doctor Who 60th anniversary
special part thr rest today so excited
two things that I got to tell you are
very important one t in the weather but
I am jacked up bunch of you Fu right now
two Is that real rejects have launched a
brand new shirt today just finished it a
couple of days ago I've been working on
this for a while take a look at his
doctor who inspired we call this the
wibbly wobbly timy wiy the doctor's
lexicon tshirt it is the T is full of a
bunch of Doctor Who quotes graffiti and
all that glorious work my sister
actually developed this one and it's
been a shirt that I've been wanting the
real rejects to have for quite some time
now I figured why not launch it now
since the specials are airing it's one
of the best ways to support the channel
we also got a bunch of other t-shirts
but go ahead Hans buy this shirt because
it'll be in the mail for us next week
can't wait to be wearing it anyway guys
leave a like on this video be very much
appreciated also big thank you to Eric
over at nerdc for editing now these
reaction highlights for us for Doctor
Who he's also one of the main people in
charge of the website passion fruit
which goes to help support other
reaction channels I've done an interview
there myself as well as many other
reactors fullly watch s with your own
copy of Doctor Who available for our
super sex rejects over at our patreon
page over there you can catch fulling
threat and watch along but we also cover
several shows exclusiv over there with
highlights and watch alongs included we
cover most of our Doctor Who uh
reactions over there as well John are
you okay you good I'm traumatized
already J do this let's get to
it going to the
Past Wonder Emporium yeah I was going to
say where's
mum there he is behold we have
everything everything you could be goant
and we have
dolls yeah we have the teddy bears and
the Harvey hor who does not want a
harvey hor and to go clip
I want a hobby hor to go
clippity Bill fa poor stooky Su and the
poor stooky babies you would leave them
without Papa cruel man you apologize for
the rain you must be used to sunnier
climbs oh what does that mean buddy
chelam being a German racist I hope the
kitties enjoy him
he's having a lot of fun with the other
the German isms may God go with
us there but by the grace of God go
I the horse of Television oo I did it
Charlie I did it the
Nickelodeon that is a jump
scare that we we chaps about to change
the
world I like this guy's
Spirit big titles Russo Brothers
text Wasteland
doctor again man this season been throw
down for practical effects and stunts
what are you doing I can't
drive okay so which
mean I'm paid for this road and I will
do with it what I like you'll get
yourself my life not yours there is uh
oh everyone started thinking their right
including me well not me what I've
always been right that's right you have
die on that Hill
buddy oh now he's
French the doctor where you are unit get
him to safety I want my Grandad safe all
right you got that yes ma'am we'll keep
your family safe yeah protect wil at all
[Music]
costs he does not remember the toy
maker that's a great shot I didn't even
know it's the Tardis a later yeah D they
got themselves an Avengers Tower Charlie
you can't be serious I'm Kate Lethbridge
Stewart and don't call me Shirley your
father working night and day to keep
unit secret and look at you now out and
proud in defending the earth oh never
mind serious hug robots and insects and
yetis and clones but what do we do this
time doctor how do we fight the human
race all those Easter eggs
listed
jeez getting down a business cuz I'm
going to need all the statistic oh no
way hey oh that is the best news Melanie
hello Legacy character Legacy character
let's
go basically every single human being
thinks they're right and won't be told
otherwise oh no what do I care why
should I care about you no change there
then hey hey watch the political
politicians are right their public
servants that's my brain activity seems
normal orbe it slightly heightened
that's Kate's
brain oh my God she's racist hello how
are you fine busy day yeah
he wants to know music is overpowering
right and I think it's highly relevant
that the person demanding information
for me is an alien I think she makes a
fair point no yeah I think she's right
in that chair I've seen you walk I've
seen you walking don't deny it you bigot
it's about time you heard the truth
activate deactivate Karen mode so the
bracelet is a metaphor for the
vaccine it's the fac OD we put on
ourselves to mask our
prejudices I'm so
sorry absolutely no need this happens
every time you demonstrate that I'm used
to it I'm wearing a zedex just in case
but I've been fine well no more
opinionated than you oh Tardis energy or
something long-term travel in the tarus
P you out of sink yeah see they are
using this to control us and monitor us
and microwave our brains I am anti- Zex
oh my God oh my God it is a metaphor is
Max oh no but coat is clean we've
checked and double checks it's not like
the old Archangel Network there's
nothing hiding in that signal
Archangel clap clap for reference
references put one on the
board maybe it's music it's
tabs oh it's a musical palindrome keg
Jak for arpeggio everyone knows arpeggio
there's a basic tune I don't even know
what arpeggio means so familiar it's
like has been buried in my head for
years have you ever taken a piano
lesson oh it's you start of Television
to laugh stooky Bill the first face to
ever appear on television put there by
John logy bed himself is that accurate
to history I don't know I never heard
these names before into television
itself and every picture ever since
every single
one everyone and everywhere he's inside
of all two
days this is the very first existence of
Television television is brainwashing us
the idiot box but something on that
scale over so many years who could do
that puppet is just a puppet we're
looking for the Puppeteer the maker of
the puppet
toy the human race might be clever and
bright and Brilliant it's also Savage
and venal and Relentless yeah the lies
the righteousness that's human that's
you that's who you are and it's all cuz
of the TV using your intelligence to be
stupid o I love that bar yeah something
else is using your worst
attributes playing with
me a game like toys oh who could do such
a thing I fed the coac fake coordinates
so it's coming into UK orbit within
ranging three minutes you're
brilliant kill her hi
why does he give them names she just
call you like number
five I'm not even going bother to learn
your name there'll be another one of you
next season time to go home I lift
office zingo and came back to Earth I've
got nothing a my family are all gone
remember yeah doctor do you remember but
then Kate offered me a job
and here I am I'd love how Kate offers
the old companions jobs yeah you should
think about joining
unit how much per year 60,000 Jesus 120
plus 5 weeks holiday done damn dude
Jesus T The Negotiator I just keep
thinking all this time you've never
mentioned her doesn't mention anything
I'm a billion years old I talk about
everyone I'd ever met we'd still be in
the Tet yapping you'll never talk about
Donna I saw you
doctor I got a glimpse inside your mind
yeah uhhuh it's like you're staggering
maybe that's why your old face came back
you're wearing yourself out
oh I forgot about that whole likeo yeah
yeah this is is peculiar isn't
it the ball is the first game ever being
invented and now everybody loves the Bor
love balls don't not go back to the
tus go back to the Tardis you never tell
me to do that oh but he is recognizing
me o are you not get pleased a doctor
after so many
years who is he not the
master oh damn we bringing back oh
actually doing flashbacks did they color
that in it looked like it if B was the
very first game what was the second hide
and
seek that came after the
ball oh good oh how fun no no no no no
no
don't now you're in a Pac-Man hallway
we've stepped ins his domain and it's
governed by the rules of play yes like
messing with
Mysterio this is impossible how does it
exist that's what unravels me it's an
illusion when I was
young I was so sure of myself I met a
terrible M when I was young but I look
so old Tardis fall into another realm a
hollow beneath the under Universe a
hollow Earth oh where science is a game
and all of us are toys that sounds
awesome I beat the to maker I won his
game but now he's here I I think it's
all because of me it's got to be I cast
that sword at the edge of the
Universe I played a game and let him in
oh damn Elemental force with the power
of a g he's driven the human race mad
with a puppet direct consequences from
the last episode Sonic and tus and Time
Lord take that away what am I now just a
lost child I don't
know if I can save your life this
time maybe I'll save
you a I hope so Donna hold on I'll lose
next time no doesn't work like that
you're the doctor man because my dad
used to say dice don't know what the
dice did last time that's true games
don't have a memory dice don't know what
the dice did last time that's that's a
clever that was really smart of you
let's just iMed it's okay you got to
keep the game progressing you got to
make a choiceed any choice left out of
behind I've got you what is it what
happened I bought a toy and I paid the
price ready
up why is he wrapped in that paper does
he have like a dummy body back to the
show he do think so yeah that's
cool oh cool
yeah got some strings to hold me up cool
creepy St that's pretty neat man I love
that demented
jigsaw yeah do you like my puppets
doctor it's like reprising the roll from
The Matrix W yes
is someone's going to make merch out of
the doctor
dummy oh hell
yes I'm s Su they took my bill away I'm
on him every day bars now the stooky
babies weep stooky bobies can sleep they
miss their kiss good night the and
Endless Night stooky
impossible took your bobies kill those
babies kill the puppies seen the cry and
now it's time to
die my name's Donna now I think you're G
bars Donna playing the game out of that
on the
spot God I'm going to miss
this show is just beginning worldwide
premere this is so whims musical let me
tell you what happened when the doctor
he was leaving you he met an a friend
called Amy P oh whoa you're going to
learn about all the companions Amy P was
touched by the V ping anel she died what
she died of old age that's not how it
happened man that's all right
then CLA CLA you skipped Rory she was
killed by a
bird Raven she still survives in her
last second of life well that's all
right
then Bill not stooky bill but lady Bill
these are just feature action figures
was killed by the cber men a they do all
die her Consciousness survives oh well
that's all right then no one walks out
just happily ever after def whoa whoa
whoa Jody Whitaker had like 14
Companions deflux was killing
everything more or less I challenge you
to a game now he mad I came to this
universe with such
delight and I played them all doctor NE
Patrick the master was dying and begged
for his life with one final game and
when he lost I sealed him for all
eternity inside my gold too
[Laughter]
those teeth oh there
face the one who Waits who weird in I
saw it hiding and I ran what do you mean
that's someone else's game no it's
coming back are we teasing some future
episode I made every opinion Supreme
that's the game of the 21st century sure
and they type and they cancel cancel C
you choose I'll go first she no sh
that's the one thing you won't do the
only rules the toy maker follows are the
rules of the game they bind his entire
existence but does he create the rules
of the game
yeah King's
High I'm the
king I won the game many years ago you
won today which leaves us equal two
players are bound by one inviable rule
best two out of three best of three best
of three then let's make it
2023 that's
harder I'm already
running oh my God I wish we could just
check back in with these two every you
know 5 10
years
woo
goodbye goodbye grimald play wa that was
great yeah that was amazing something
entered this world in 1925 I don't know
how and I warn you this thing can get
from 1925 to now like stepping through a
door an elemental Force beyond the rules
of the universe the Parker Brothers
could you turn that off please who is
that no one turns the Spice Girls
off oh
yes get off all of them get the the
German one the French one the British
one SP up be
life
oh oh my
god well and that's how that companion
died no
don't yeah
whoa everything everywhere all at Doctor
Who punch line oh my God it's like
Thanos with a reality Stone
boom and American
Beauty up your life people of the world
spice up your life a have
[Laughter]
demented I need more flowers in my gun
yes how does he do that if I told you he
manipulates atoms with a power of
thought would you believe it is that
what he
does oh my God he's got the galvanic
beam there's a game how I am liking
this
boang boom he's like Riddler and Joker
combined I don't understand why you're
so
small what don't call me that you know
full well this is merely a face
concealing a vastness that will never
cease because you're good and you're bad
are nothing to me good or bad is
subjective you know full well that I've
had many
faces containing something far more but
why this face so come with me come with
me now we can take your games back to
the Stars we can play across the cosmos
forever we can
be
Celestial the time lord and the toy
maker infinite games infinite PR that
would be something special yeah and
yet I have fallen in love with Humanity
sure you have Shackled to their bedrooms
with their joysticks and their buttons
suffer the little children out of bricks
falling upon other bricks you are
exceptional the dating and ghosting the
deceit and the control you make me dizzy
the dark complexity of the humans no
fight is with
me
one more
yo what is in a galvanic beam I played
the second game with this doctor is this
going to lead to the Regeneration play
the third game with the next Doctor what
a transition damn are we doing it
now he's not dying alone is this right
now I guess sudden I'm going to be with
it so am I and my
ax it's not dying I know but you're
going to be someone else soak up some of
that time lord juice it doesn't matter
who cuz every single one of you is
fantastic e used to say that
fantastic here we go again oh no I'm not
ready how long how long
I don't think it's going to
happen they're messing with
[Music]
us pull pull my
finger you what do you mean just pull is
he like a party popper now feels
different this time can he
stretch
what
who what
what is it like a binary situation I
guess
maybe or a
non-binary there going to be two doctors
a
quinary y man I'm you I'm me what a way
to introduce no I'm me really really
me completely
me don't just s push oh this is push
changing up the way we go about Doctor
Who for sure new regeneration rules he's
got pants
on
he in his ties it's good someone tell me
what the hell is going on
here how did that happen by
generation I have by generated by
generation is supposed to be a myth but
by generation get the Myth Busters here
I think you're
beautiful still beautiful yeah did you
come in a range of colors yes
you I could play this for a hundred
years I'll have vast Meadows of doct and
I'll never get bored because I challenge
you to a game oh
yeah I'm the doctor and I'm the doctor
and according to the rules you can't say
no it's your game and you did this this
is so so bizarre name your challenge
doctor the first game ever the ball yes
catch it's a simple game really but I
think if you drop it you lose don't drop
it
nice do it like a hacky sack I really
wonder how people are going to respond
to this rule
yeah yeah is hi I'm so
sorry
interesting not
bad
[Music]
alop you know this is a pretty epic game
of catch one might even call it
[Music]
Legend oh no to do
best to four out of five and my prize
toy maker is to banish you from
existence forever what it's
not
can't this is just like his rule in The
Matrix is he making him a flat
Stanley my Legions are
coming Legions of Legions
Legion we did it but how many died down
there that's not your fault you're just
Ken yeah
a it's okay masculine tenderness I like
it
a literally get to embrace
yourself oh the master will return who
just grabbed it who hand is that who
just grabbed it you're thin as a pin
love you've been running on fumes that's
what I keep saying oh so we're like
starting a new with this guy yeah that
doctor that first met the toy maker
never ever stopped that very first put
on trial exiled key to time all the
devastation of lopis all those classic
episodes River
Song River Song Sarah Jane has gone can
you believe that for a second but her
Chronicles I loved
her end Rose but the time wor
Pandora car mavic Chen we're saying
goodbye to a whole era you're fine I'm
fine because you fixed yourself we time
Lords were doing rehab out of order o
he's saying you need to stop you need to
take a CH her relax cuz you know what I
did I
lived day after day after day would
drive me
mad yeah it does us all it does the one
Adventure you've never had whoa you
changed your face a cuz we're in love
know cuz she can show him the path to
chilling
out
a finally come to
[Music]
dinner I'm still having a hard time
wrapping my head around this whole by
generation thing but I could never let
the Tardis
go what
if what if oh oh what do you got in some
pants hey watch this watch this watch
watch watch watch stand back stand back
wish me luck what for we won the game
you get a prize
honey here is
mine oh what is happening what is
happening I cannot wrap my head around
this oh my God everybody gets a
series oh look
hey a ramp
woke oh he's got the
Jukebox it's nothing but Leonard Skinner
tunes on there it's all
Freebird now you two if you don't mind
there is a great big universe out there
calling and I've got to get going so off
your pop old man he's younger cuz you
came after him so you're the older
doctor okay kid old white guy always
wins
a how
cool Charlie don't suppose you've seen
this before don't see it off myself and
don't call me
surely good luck good luck and the one
with the flowers is a chicken I still
feel like we're going to be following
the doctor yeah I know I mean tenant you
know with my best friend my
brother-in-law the evil stepmother oh I
have barely begun I'm mad Auntie Mel mad
aren't you Mel and Grandpa wolf and
Granddad where is he oh he's off
shooting
moles there he is now W lives funny
thing is I fought all those battles for
all those
years and now I know what for to retire
I've never been so happy in my life
oh
[Music]
buddy what do we
got toss a coin in that
jukebox so interesting we thought
Timeless child CH up the Lord
know like d like I'm going to up y'all
yeah we're not resetting all
right
destination
Christmas that's to wrap your goddamn
head around that's for sure all righty
well I've got I've got a lot of Praise
okay and I've got a lot of questions
sure that might lead to criticisms
depending on the answers specifically
John gives me wow you hate Doctor Who no
no no not at all I actually quite
enjoyed the hell out of this episode my
criticisms will be mild there more
concerns depending on the answers John
gives me I have so many answers G this
is why we need an ending explained yes I
honestly I mean for something like this
yeah it is sort of like what are the
rules exactly I could use it I could use
it let's unpack our feelings as we go um
before we go into any of that just
another reminder that one of the best
ways to support the channel is reject
naations shop.com where you can get
yourself some RR apparel and we got
shirts like chop protection services for
Pedro Pascal baby grou space babies of
the Galaxy but of course we got our
recently launched Doctor Who tshirt yeah
baby Alon bunch of other quotes decked
out on the Tardis also if you're
listening this on Apple and Spotify
please rate this video now John I'm John
you're John uh here's what I loved
here's what I loved I love The Madness
of this episode I thought it was a lot
of fun I think these specials I quite
enjoyed all of them my favorite would
still probably be wild blue y
uh and this would be uh it would go 2 3
1 yeah for me I think I agree I like
them all but I like them in that order I
like them in that order specifically um
but I I loved how this had a little bit
of that absurdest horror I thought Neil
Patrick Harris was a lot of fun I
thought I'd be distracted that it was
Neil Patrick Harris the whole time just
like in The Matrix movie sure where I
was really distracted I don't remember
what his character was it wasn't the
architect it was something else the
analyst yeah I always I don't know why I
really really got a gripes with with him
in that movie for some reason just I was
so distracted that it was Neil Patrick
Harris the entire time but anyway that's
beside the point I really I believed him
as the character of the toy maker here
and I I thought he had so much fun with
the different accents that he was doing
like he he just he brought his stage
presence to life here I thought and um I
I thought it was a great delight and and
a wonderful foil for the doctor oh yeah
and in every account and in terms of
like what they did with the by
Generation Um there were so many moments
that I thought were very tender and
touching you know like what what's his
name 15th doctor uh shti gatwa yeah okay
it's GNA be a while before I call him
that let's call let's call 15 for a
while 15 all
right Dr g i I will I'll remember it by
next week all right you got this so 15th
doctor uh when like 15th hugged 14 I
thought that was a really sweet moment
because the only one who could really
understand the pain would be 15 um 14
being able to say there there things
contextually that uh even outside of my
questions that I really love
like you know you had uh one through
eight
doctor show
cancelled or ended or whatever right I a
prolonged break took a prolonged break
there's a movie in between and some
other stories they told and then they
come back with nine yeah and now they've
ended this era from 9 to 14 they've
ended that era essentially the story at
least because they're going to start
over with 15 yes you know so I I love
how we got to have certain goodbyes you
know tenant got Rose you know what I
just realized they never mentioned
Martha and all that like companion talk
yeah that's they mentioned Rose they
mentioned bill they mention Amy
mentioned Rose Bill Amy and uh they
didn't mention any of Whitaker's no
Whitaker had like 12 companions yeah and
I guess for the most part they're
they're mostly fine I guess so that's a
little different like I guess of all the
companions they they don't have the the
harshest lives to get back to still did
not mention any of them sure yeah um and
I'm surprised that they would Overlook
Martha cuz she was a she was a good one
what happened with her sh end up with
Mickey or some I for like she she
does something it doesn't matter yeah um
so I I loved I loved uh 15's um
performance you know you're going to get
both in this one episode yeah and you
really got to distinguish them and I and
I I enjoyed his introductory performance
quite a bit H and he takes command of
the screen felt comfortable and I loved
that tenant was really sharing the
screen with him and it was interesting
because a lot of times when you get you
know your collabs with the doctors it's
be you've been take take the other
special when you had Smith and tenant
yeah you know you've been hanging out
with Smith for a while then tenant comes
back and it's the nostalgic crossover
element of hey look at these two
crossing over together and this is
completely different where I am
literally going to be sharing the screen
with you whilst introducing you to the
world it's a completely different gamble
yeah yeah that's a very hard thing I and
I for Imagine what's his
name 15 Chuy gatwa chuti gatwa yeah
chuty we could start there I think yeah
it's it's yeah we could start with Chuy
chy the last name okay godwa godwa chuty
the last name is the easy part it's it's
chuty sounds way easier to me say well
it's when you look at it it's spelled
ncuti so it's for americ don't throw
that in my bra John don't throw that in
my name chti chy got one I can remember
chy cuz I I imagine it spell totally
different sure chti phonetic phonetics
excuse me guys I'm a little under the
weather stomach is also killing me I got
this like big stomach pain bloat
happening at the same time you were in
the worst shape imaginable but Doctor
Who I'm willing to keep going still
bringing the joy I got to do this so
chti um uh yeah everything about his
performance was great and and and I
think that for him to be introduced here
uh I I'm like yeah I'm looking forward
to seeing what he does there was so much
I really loved about
it what do you think John before I get
to my questions I enjoyed this verily I
enjoyed this quite a bit this has uh I
think it's One Last Thing Before I
Forget before I just before I just let
myself settle with my little symptoms
for a while please I'm sorry John get it
out get it out we discussed this prior I
so okay the the how like Rose had a
tragic ending in some ways right
initially yeah but then she got to be
off with Tennant yeah yeah yeah and and
Donna had tragedy Beall her in in a lot
of ways and there was a a Darkness to
her you know if she remembers she'll die
meta crisis all that yeah but she's able
to they're able to have this like sweet
tenderness like who knows how long 14
would be there but this is the exact
antithesis to the kind of life that the
doctor never thought he'd be able to
live yeah and now he gets to have the
opportunity to live that and I think
that is so so sweet and
unexpected and and a big part of why I
like the choice of what they did yeah
yeah you get the sense he actually gets
to rest for the first time the doctor
rests and now um as you should now I'll
let you uh talk for a little bit before
before we get to fix stuff no I I I've
like I said and we've touched on really
enjoyed all three of these specials and
it's been such a lovely thing to have
David Tennant and kathern Tate back
especially and all of our sort of
surrounding players and unit and things
like that both new and old uh and yeah
this was an episode that certainly I
think they did a nice kind of Trio here
that's proportionate in that yeah you
have uh the first episode uh you know
which is very much kind of doing uh I
don't know I it felt kind of like a
synthesis of the Whitaker reintroduction
but going back to the tone of the tenant
era especially um and yeah you're you're
you know kind of dealing with a
terrestrial thing here at home then in
the second one you're dealing with an
isolated very sci-fi thing out in the
future and then these two episodes the
middle and the last one both go into the
past for certain little historical
details uh which I thought was really
nice and apparently uh uh I think his
name was John loie be is a real guy that
whole thing with the TV is you know
based on actual History stooky Bill uh
is a real you know puppet from history I
love when they do that stuff and yeah
this episode had especially um a lot of
just the the Aesthetics that appeal to
me directly of like you pointed out the
sort of like trippy gothic stuff they're
doing when they're in like the infinite
Scooby-Doo hallway and you've got the
demented mannequin uh you ventriloquist
dummy dolls and uh and yeah you've got
these like circus elements and stuff
like that I I really enjoyed the Whimsy
and the and the madness of
the toy maker and his presence here and
yeah I think that NPH you know it can go
either way because I'm a fan I enjoy him
but yeah it depends on what the thing is
and there are certain things you watch
where you're like yeah he's perfect for
this and it and he Blends in really
nicely with everything around and then
there are some things like I get your
point with the Matrix where it is like
I'm kind of aware of that I'm watching
you specifically and I get that maybe
that's part of the point um but I think
that plays better here because yeah like
you know you're watching NPA Ag and he
is big but I liked that he clearly you
know brought all of his you know utmost
Showmanship and flamboyant and I like
the whole thing with the accents going
back from the geram to you know the
French a little bit I I don't know much
about the original toy maker other than
learning that it was Michael Goff who's
you know a prolific British actor was
Alfred and the Tim Burton Batman and
stuff that's who that was and that
character was like a a kind of an Asian
stereo typ so they you know adjusted it
Fu man cheu kind of yeah that would have
been way better yeah we just have Neil
Patrick Harris going all Cloud Atlas on
us but uh but yeah like I thought that
they tempered the history seen Cloud
Atlas I have not I just know you are
speaking out of line know that Asian
face plot line had everybody uh really
really really appreciative must
experience context before declaring
correct context I want to see it uh but
yeah I liked his presentence I liked
what he brought I liked the movie does
do that the way they just you know I get
the choice from the outside from the
vague things I've heard but maybe
problematic you know maybe problematic
uh but yeah I like the way they updated
the from what I understand the little I
know about the original character from
way back in you know the the beginnings
of Doctor Who I liked what they updated
him to here and yeah I I like that it
was something that is largely here in
the present with our major characters
kind of reconnecting to yeah here's our
Ensemble commemorating all the time that
we have spent together especially with
unit bringing back old Companions and
and we did see Mel briefly at like the
companion support group at the end of
the Whitaker season she's not one of the
ones that like I don't think is you know
like coming back and helping directly
because we had the other two uh but uh
but yeah like all those things were nice
um and yeah I I if anything I was just
like man I could do with another like 15
minutes on this cuz the the third act
like is it's a it's Doctor Who so so the
third Act is truncated and it's a
special it's longer than a normal
episode but it's still like 55 minutes
and I'm like ah man this is the time
where you could go for an hour 10 or
something like that and and you know I I
bought most everything I do have
questions about stuff uh I like
generally that they're making some of
these choices though just because I mean
yeah they're they're obviously nodding
to certain aspects of our culture
especially with the whole uh Motif they
used of uh the uh Toy uh Toy Maker you
know creating this game where everybody
basically assumes that they are just
like of the utmost Authority and
everyone assumes that they're correct in
all of their opinions and that sort of
boiling over into chaos that's very
relevant to our times and whatnot how uh
you know cuz uh I'm right and I said so
and you shouldn't question me when I'm
speaking cuz I know what I'm talking
[Music]
about um yeah like I like all that stuff
and I like that you know in coming back
to tenant with these three episodes and
Katherine Tate you know going back to
something lovely and familiar you're
kind of able to have your cake and eat
it to because throughout the tone and
the themes they've been like no we are
not going to stop you know addressing
the real world and creating these you
know uh they're not like the most deeply
veiled allegories but you know like
stuff that obviously has touchstones to
Modern Life we're not going to stop
doing that um and so I I I thought they
were super subtle in this episode they
were the subtlest um but I do I'm of two
minds I I'm by generated now because
part of me and I know there was so much
with the Timeless child that people
don't like uh it's always hazardous when
you're adding new lore I I would be
curious to go back and you answering
question terrain or criticism terrain uh
question terrain more than anything
thing maybe I don't have a direct
criticism right now for the the I do
okay I don't okay just damn it have one
let's fight um yeah I I it's always I
would if anybody wants to comment and
shouts out to Rosie over at the patreon
I'm sure you would be a great you know
person to put this list together for me
but like I'm curious to have an
amalgamation of all the things that the
new series starting at eckl and Beyond
has added to the rules in the can and I
know that they recontextualized the 12
regenerations into a more unlimited
thing uh and now we have this by
generation I appreciate that they're not
resting on the old lore I think that's
one piece of friction spot of friction
that we run into with all of these
beloved properties now is like you can
only change the lore in certain ways and
and you know there's always going to be
a Grace with which you need to uh you
know proceed in order to do that um but
I do appreciate that they are you know
not resting on you know the old stuff
and as much as we do have a lovely boost
of nostalgia in the circumstances here
it's also like no we're going to keep
adding new ideas to what the lore can be
and how it can work and so yeah I'm
still chewing and processing the the by
generation chewy as a yeah we're home uh
as a concept uh But Here and Now like at
face value I like it you know like it's
and that whole thing about like I we
thought this was a myth you know like
the idea exists or at least we've
acknowledged in this episode that the
myth exists um now we never have to say
goodbye to any doctor that's the fear
and I mean that's there's already
reasons why you don't have to say
goodbye to any doctor because they can
bring them all back somehow but like now
we can just have a big cinem and I we
get a new doctor every episode well and
I don't know what the context was but
well and I you know what though I part
of me thought like maybe we talked about
this at one point I don't know but like
having a season where it's it's like a
new doctor every episode would be C do
it like The Daily Show trying to replace
Trevor Noah where they're like we don't
know what to do so let's just get
everybody uh like I think that would be
fun but uh but yeah like it on the one
hand I could see it opening a door to
like well then you can just always do
this you can just have infinite doctors
and and it's like the toy maker says I
could just do this forever and have a
meadow of you um and I haven't read too
far into it I don't know what the plans
are I I've heard Russell T Davies has
aspirations to you know expand out the
reach of what this universe can be and
certainly sending tenant off like this I
think is is interesting because on the
one hand it's a really lovely bow on
everything that he has done if he never
returned to the role after this which I
assume even if they didn't buy generate
I assume he would at least in a small
way at some point but uh in doing this I
feel like you have a nice resting point
for him it's the lovely thing the
doctor's never able to do and with
tenant we've certainly confronted number
of times where it's like I'm not going
to come in for dinner I'm going to peace
out I'm going to do the Irish goodbye
and now he gets to have that lovely sort
of rest with his you know chos that was
the Easter egg yep when he said when he
said you're not going to leave without
saying goodbye yeah that was the Easter
egg yeah I tried to do that to
Donna as it's messed up man no when
when um 15 oh that's right and he was
going to do it's what you do man yeah
see and now and it's not going to do it
now and it's it's gross no man he's not
going to do it but also at the same time
you're like well this does also give you
an ex a direct opening to have just two
series he's got a freaking Tardis of his
if they put him without his own tardis
I'd be like yeah the doctor's going to
live ostensibly happily ever after or 14
is uh but on the other hand I'm like
well you can kind of do what you want so
it's it's conscientious and that they
don't have to but they easily can um
it's just a little I guess my initial
concern is it's a little it's like an
initial concern it all depends on how
they handled it moving forward M it's
the way how people complain about
anything with like Marvel or Star Wars
like god let's let these characters die
you know and the doctor Never Dies he's
already Immortal yeah and I'm like part
of me is a little concerned of is this
too Immortal now sure I've already
gotten on board with the immortality
like honestly Timeless child stuff did
not really bother John and I uh it it
didn't really bother me be because I
think we just kind of watched it as one
binge yeah whereas everyone else kind of
has like I watch it and then I have a a
little bit of a breather and I just I
digest it and absorb it and especially
for those who absorb classic who I could
understand I get what's not to love yeah
I I I can totally get that but for in
the immediacy of watching it I was I
remember being like all right
interesting okay fine you're clearly a
special of some kind even amongst a
special race such as the time Lords yeah
yeah yeah so I was like all right
whatever I'll I'll go on board yeah and
I'm kind of I'm kind of at of the same
mind but I'm also weirdly more con
whereas like the Timeless child I I
think opened up I can't remember what
positive thing it opened up for me nor
was I like a negative about it you know
yeah and here this at least opens up
positive doors MH and then it opens up
doors of concern of kind of emotionality
weight is is the is really the only
thing right cuz it's not really it
doesn't really make a difference uh you
know because he still gets every new
doctor the 16th if it's a by generation
instead of a regeneration they would
still get the memories of 1 through 15
that's the question actually is are they
going to do it so that and I've I've in
the vague I mean 15 has has everyone's
memories 14 and
on 14 and before doesn't he I'm not sure
well I'm not sure it certainly would
seem as though but part of me wonders if
in splitting them apart and in
restarting at series one again because
they've said they're doing that this is
a new series one with 15 but to cut you
off I thought to cut you off to cut you
off what to cut you off oh I was totally
just talking I had no idea you were even
talking my days have saying sorry to
interrupt they done I'm going to cut you
off take it or leave it but I'm talking
now and I'll just turn your mic down if
I
have sorry what were you gon to cut me
off oh I don't even remember now it's
okay I just wanted to make my joke it's
okay it was about 15 we were talking
about 15 the memories did I have an
actual point I don't know it sounded it
sure sounded like you did oh um I could
think of one what were we talking about
we were talking about whether or not 15
has all the memories of the doctors
which is a good question to ask oh to
cut you off yes and didn't they say with
with the ninth doctor wasn't that a
series one yeah that that's that is yeah
exactly and that was a reboot of some
kind and I don't know I mean ecken
certainly as the doctor seem to have
some of the past traumas of being the
doctor so I don't really know what the
reboot means in a time where there
hasn't been a massive break to come back
from um and I wonder if I don't know it
just makes me curious because what gets
divided in the by regenerating and what
gets changed it's like are they both
100% Time Lord or is this something
where like we had the thing with tenant
and Rose earlier where okay you have
like human doctor which I get the
circumstances were different for that
and you know it's it's just a human
version that can grow old different
thing but at the same time it makes you
wonder like okay is tenant going to kind
of carry on the memories and maybe gotwa
will be the kind of a fresher slate than
that maybe or maybe not I don't know oh
I think that's way too much if they do
that okay see that's the pro like you
got to think about if like the when the
by generation keeps happening like just
the multiplication process of that well
I think the key is to not do it much I
think the the the thing is they've set
up a device that can work but that the
that you absolutely have to not get
carried away with and not use as an
excuse just to have fun all the time
well I think that I think that's my
question is does okay when um 15th tenur
is done then we get to 16th is it a
going to be a by gener I mean we will
we won't okay so you highly see I was
under the impression that that's how
it's going to be from here on out I
think that's just because this is a
special with David
Tenant I think it's because of his
legacy and of all the new doctors he's
easily the one everybody carals around
and agrees on the most I think if it was
just if you know in a scenario where
it's just 50 or if it was just jod
Whitaker regenerating on her own and no
special yeah I I don't think that would
happen so much cuz I don't think there's
as much of a reason to be like now I'm
excited about two doctors I've never met
before versus now I'm excited because
one I love from before still carries on
okay that that's what was concerning me
about emotional weight because there's
such a there's such a thing to saying
goodbye because when as an audience
member you are saying goodbye to the the
you're saying goodbye to the actor mhm
um and it it feels like you are leaving
someone behind as a character still yeah
like when you when Whitaker left or when
Tennant first left or whomever when
Smith first left you feel like you are
saying goodbye e yeah you are you feel
like you are saying goodbye to this
character still yeah even though the
doctor will carry on you still feel like
you're saying goodbye to this person and
meeting someone new and I don't have
that feeling now with with tenant yeah
it's like oh well I could probably see
him again and now we're just going to
focus our attention on someone else and
that feeling of saying goodbye is
something that I hold kind of dear to
the Doctor Who experience yeah of kind
of putting some sense even though it's
like I know they can come back in some
special or uh they can do something
right like you know yeah there's there
is a sense of he's just out there of of
something that feels a little more
finite when for a character who is
infinite you know yeah um and and I I
treasure that feeling and I think that's
an important feeling to maintain agree
and that's the concern about the by
generation 100% 100% oh you know like I
don't really I don't know how people
might read into it as something else as
a result of like the non-binary stuff
that was uh you know upsetting the world
um and and people tweet about it those
folks will stop existing I will say I
think
Russ I think and I will say like Russell
T Davies is writing uh particularly in
the first and third episode when it
comes to uh certain political statements
he wants to let you know oh yeah he's
like right wigers you listening to my
thoughts my little antix riff here's my
Twitter riff yeah yeah totally he does
get very very aggressive to the pointone
where I I'm aware that you are now
writing a message like I know that you
want to rile up a certain group of
people right now I I completely get the
the sentiment of like I like it because
it's just so freaking it's so bold it's
so on the nose it's so on the nose but
it seems clear that that's what it wants
to do it's so confidently on the nose
that I don't mind it where I'm like if
it's one thing if when you think you're
being subtle but you're not that's when
that's when it annoys me you know again
I liken it to Barbie of of like Barbie's
so on the nose I'm like that's that's
what it's about that's what they're
doing you know and and that's what I
feel like I'm watching her with Doctor
Who was like yeah I see what you're
doing because you're making it clear
like yeah if we're going to do it might
as well not be might as well go a little
ham fist about it yeah um so yeah uh I I
will give it that and and that's my
concern with the by generation and my
other question is is um okay so when it
comes to the face
yeah I do think that if eckleson was
willing to come back they would have
brought back ecken I I weirdly feel like
for the arc they set forward sure
although you know it's like you would
need it for Rose I mean uh Donna you
would need it for Donna yeah rose
already has her by
um
yeah but man whatever the hell happened
with
Eon just get like little nuggets that
keep coming out um but I'm like oh no
that real run is done when you when you
get that yeah when you get the
e that's when that's when it's really
done because even though he's done I I
think he's in like audio books or
something I some audio appearances uh is
it not audio books but some something
yeah some weird audio
radio stories or yeah whatever whatever
an audio play becomes in the modern time
yeah I think he's done some yeah when
when that that to me would really feel
like the that is the end of the doctor
of that run that would be a big surprise
yeah because because part of me is
sitting here going okay when are we
going to get uh Mass Smith back at some
point for a special occasion when are we
going to get Kabal back at some point
for a special occasion and he's older
certainly uh so you know we got less
time for that and but yeah yeah like
with eckl there's that back and forth of
like you know that there's certain
friction it doesn't seem like he's
always the easiest person to to work
with on these things I've heard him say
that there was some conduct on set he
wasn't a fan of and I've also heard yeah
oh eckelson is yeah he's he's uh he
didn't like the little things have come
out and you can kind of just piece it
all together over because he like he
likes to like reveal a little bit at a
time but yeah he didn't get along with
that all with the crew and I think him
and him he wanted to work see Davies
again and I think that when it came time
for Doctor hoop time yeah uh they were
not getting along and then there was the
other director too he wasn't getting
along with because I think in recent
years he has kind of recanted a bit and
been like oh I didn't realize exactly
the
mantle in the time that I was stepping
into the mantle I didn't realize you
know kind of what that would mean and
and what it would mean to people and and
just how a different side of of this
apparatus operates in terms of the and
and the love and all that stuff and so
like part of me does hold out hope that
maybe someday he could come back and
yeah in a way he said he said he would
come back if it was like a solo thing he
doesn't want to do a crossover okay I I
can I from what from the amount I know
about Christopher eckleson I could see
that it's like he would probably want to
come back for for some kind of special
that he gets to do the heavy lifting for
and that like isn't oh be a fun like few
minutes of screen time with a bunch of
other doctors I I got to imagine yeah he
he was to really show up and act which
I'm happy with I like his doctor a lot
but I also yeah like it it to end the
era and to reset the era it would feel
the fullest Circle and I guess it's just
lucky that everyone loves tenant so much
because that works too but yeah I get
what you mean it's like well I like
tenant more certainly I can't disagree I
I as we have gone on like because I I
really like Christopher Eckles and I
have a soft spot in my heart for that
doct
you know as being my first but uh but
yeah I mean I'm not going to say that
he's the best one of the new series
necessarily because I don't think he was
around long enough to really like hit
that full-on stride man you know like
sure yeah yeah I like what he did a lot
I like the flavors of his doctor but
like you get to tenant and you're just
like wow there's just so much more time
to spread out and really embody and
inhabit this and then Smith and Capaldi
and blah blah blah they just all feel
like they lead into each other a bit
more naturally than eckleson into any of
the rest of them well well okay so the
tenic comes back
because what was the reasoning do you
remember well that something about
showing me something something I got so
caught up in the by generation thing
that I'm like nothing else matters to me
right now I need to understand this by
generation thing it was one of those
emot I I like that this season or this
Trio of specials has also had those
emotional beats where Donna implies here
that it's like and she says it and 15
also says it it's uh it's like you're
you're running ragged you know like
you're you're stretching thin and you're
exhausted and maybe this is some sort of
attempt to like uh return to something
warm and familiar and to find an old
friend and in that way it's it's funny
cuz yeah it's like if you had eckl for
this these specials or at least this
special and you have Rose that makes
sense because they are such an iconic
duo in a lot of ways but I think yeah
like do and Donna also makes beautiful
sense I think they like there are a lot
of great Companions and you can talk all
day about who's great and why and you
know why this might have worked with
Martha or somebody else but I think yeah
like Katherine Tate being back with
tenant is such a lovely dynamic they are
a great set of characters and I I think
it's yeah it's that emotional thing of
like instead of it being some kind of
Grand trick or a master plan or a toy
maker plan it's maybe it's just some
subconscious cry to you know get back to
something warm and familiar some kind of
uh love support Etc and maybe actually
take a load off and rest after all this
well yeah it seems like the the only way
he could have had the opportunity to
slow down and Netflix and chill and have
a home of any kind at all it wouldn't be
with any other compan Canon it would be
maybe with Mel cuz she's probably living
in an old folks home with her
$60,000 she's got the support group
she's got the Y support
group oh yes yeah yeah she I I didn't
catch it at first but yeah she shows up
in the support group at the end there of
the Whit her run Mel yeah she's not one
of the the main focus like there are a
couple other companions one's called
Tegan I forget the other one's name yeah
they like yeah not one of the two that's
like on the adventure but she's there at
the end in that like Roundup of
companion cameos I like how they made
justifications for why he was an old man
when he was kaliy sure they did not make
justifications for why he was a young
hot professor at a college University
when he was Matt Smith
yeah you know he's like I'm just I'm
younger baby about cool and now season
one new season one we're just going to
spend all this time being like I decid
to be
black you can choose that's why I chose
a black face I chose to be a
black open up some weird racial
implications they pick they really pick
and choose when they decided make make
something about the identity of
appearance I me I think there's fun to I
don't recall anything about like that's
why I came as a woman yeah I don't
recall anything about that were just
rolling with it there's little cuse in
culture currently to be like why did I
generate as a 30s something's white guy
you know whereas like if it's a woman or
if it's any other ethnicity or whatever
it's out of the ordinary well I can't
wait to see 15 go to like time periods
as a black doctor that where it would be
really hard to just kind of oh yeah
everyone's going to be racist all the
time all the stuff Ryan companion dealt
with when they would go to certain eras
yeah or Martha yeah mhm or other black
characters who would travel with Doctor
sure sure I mean he's going to have to
experience that now yeah and I mean
it'll be interesting to see how it
manifests when it's the doctor and not
like an alien race or
some or when there's a white savior to
save their black companion yeah you got
your white card Black savior yeah saving
himself sure being free of all the
the bigotry all the concern of other
people's narrow-mindedness but it would
be really interesting for Russell T
Davies to write an episode similar to
the Capaldi episode when he's like why
did I choose this old face yes why
for get so CAU why did I choose this
black knowing that Russell T D why did I
choose this blackface a and then Russell
T there you can make a lot of commentary
man but maybe you shouldn't do this
maybe you should let a black riter
handle this episode or you know just
like let not talk about it yeah I mean
yeah like that's always an interesting
facet and it makes me wonder again like
how much of that how self-reflexive
they're going to do uh go with the new
iteration or not because that's I feel
like that's always a part of it too is
like every doctor has some kind of
torture but you know some of them are
more self-reflective than
others yeah but as an episode as a whole
it was really fun M you know um and I do
I do agree I think it should have been a
little bit longer cuz like by the time
it got to like oh he's going to
regenerate like I was about to be like
what this just came out of
nowhere what the and I like the
game of catch but it is a a bit like oh
oh and we're done oh it just you threw
the thing and he didn't catch it and
we're done oh okay interesting yeah yeah
yeah so I I did think that it was like
okay now we're moving along like we're
moving through some like really quick
like the beats that you must go through
through for your regeneration and or or
Now by Generation episode like you you
you must go through those beats but
admittedly I was like this is this is
happening kind of I didn't really feel
like we built to this moment at all this
feels like a transition into something a
bigger finale or something yeah I I
think I think one thing too when it
comes to regenerations or by Generations
is uh or any kind of you know new
introduction uh one thing I will hold
dear is you kind of have to make the
episode sort of feel like it's sort of
about that or really building up to it
in some way yeah you know even if it's
not like the whole time they're just
fighting against it you there's got to
be some type of inkling of we are on our
way to a goodbye yeah and I think that
would have sell the by generation moment
even better if it was like oh we're
building up oh we're going to say I have
to say goodbye to tenant one more time a
this is going to be hard hard oh here
what not just oh my God is it already
happening yeah and then also on top of
it's already happening now there's like
a whole new wrinkle of lore and it's
double happening what's happening yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I think that's why
they I mean even though the tenant thing
was spoiled for us that was impossible
when it came from Whitaker to tenant um
that whole even that episode I I think
that's why the impact was beyond just
being tenant coming back I think that
was another reason with the with the big
impact was all right let's see what the
new doctors after building up to it in
this episode knowing it's the final
episode um for now yeah but damn man
dude and apparently I didn't know this I
like Whit girl a lot I wish w I wish she
would get more love I thought she was
great I I would and I would be really
excited for whatever crossover event
brings her back at some point I think
they should absolutely bring her back at
some point really did she really took
care of my mommy issues for me I felt
like she was comforting me and giving me
the nurturing I didn't receive growing
she was hey respect Jody Whit was
terrific in the role I know and I also
thought she was very physically
attractive so it really played on the Ed
I thought she was terrific in the role
really did play my the hottest doct uh
one thing I learned which I didn't
realize is that uh part of what enticed
Russell T Davy's back to this world was
uh you know our reactions on
patreon a stream events yeah actually
there was like a big stream along event
that somebody was doing during the
pandemic that got like Steven Moffet
back on Twitter and then Russell T
Davies was like damn I got to check this
out too and like man everyone's tuning
in at the same time and doing this live
watch watch this people watch this
and they do it together online what
what this is this is this is these just
we were just making these for us all
right well time to get some uh left
agendas out there yeah that's what the
internet
loves
yeah yeah so you know stream alongs
watch alongs we we we we got Doctor Who
we save we saved Doctor Who or something
I don't
know I
mean I like yeah I don't think Doctor
Who really needed to be saved but it
needed to be saved from some tonal
issues but other than
that but but yes in closing as long as
they don't I'll be happy with this stuff
if they don't buy generate all the time
and if we don't see tenant for a while
is is kind of I wonder I think every
other episode should be tenant well part
of me wonders if they're going to use
him as like a as like a resource like ah
we we've run into a a conundrum
let's stop by you know chisik and ask
David tennis and then like even with
like the second Tardis I'm like what
some you know there's just some stuff oh
and the master and he's in the gold
tooth that's right master in the gold
tooth and who grabbed the tooth oh dude
that was uh I think it was um was it
Kate would it be K would you pull a
maneuver like that maybe to well it's
certainly seem like a sneaky thing not
like we got to keep this tooth under
lock and key we got to go through
everyone's hands and see the nail polish
yeah and be detectives yeah or we just
wait for some other editor on YouTube to
figure out like it's definitely this
hand if you look at this other
from this episode and that episode
oh cool good to know Masters and we did
see it dude and then we got Christmas in
a couple of weeks
excited to see uh yeah I'm excited to
spend Christmas with you I am excited to
come here Christmas you'll be here day
Christmas Day right I will be here Chas
edit and and then you can edit it all
day and I'll sit across the room and be
like you're doing great now you're
killing the game right now they be like
no you can't go back to your family we
have you have to keep me company while I
work on do your gift to me is to be here
for the next 5 to8 hours while I edit
and thumbnail and upload and assemble
this for the people it's red nail polish
on those fingers who was wearing red Mel
had red hair maybe she took oh my God is
it is the is uh the paraplegic woman oh
that's right she rolled over there maybe
no one saw yeah no one would suspect me
I'm in a wheelchair well she can get out
of the wheelchair here in there so maybe
it could be I'm like who else had red
nail polish damn no I don't know it
can't be Donna Donna becomes the new
master master Donna dude is that who I
think it is no it's random number damn
it spam spam call sorry yeah all right
well I'm going to be scrubbing for the
next few hours for red nail polish and
last nope ready to go home now yeah well
get out of here was a good episode liked
it a lot it a great series of specials I
can't wait to cosplay as 15 dude you
just fear my underw get I would be
overjoyed if that's his outfit I think
for the Christmas special he should just
be we should just wear we should just
wear tidy
Whitey and white button downs and then
we'll double down and do blackface yes I
think we should it'll be like hey if the
doctor can regenerate why can't we yeah
why can't we choose our
face I'll be the new Rachel dozol baby
I'm taking the right lessons aren't I
yeah this is yeah this is the woke
agenda they wanted to inspire in us
right yeah you should do it I mean I'm
down for the underwear bit I'm down for
the underwear bit bit if P we might be
able to just keep it going for all the
2024 I'll have to do some squats in the
meantime all right well if you made it
this far hopefully uh I don't know when
we'll get that Christmas specialty you
guys that'll be a while it'll be
February 2021 I might just might just
catch up like right before the new
season comes out somewhere between
Christmas
maybe the I I need I'm going to want a
little bit of a break take a load off if
anyone on Earth deserves a few days off
for the holidays it is it's Ryan it's
Ryan Ary you don't do yeah I don't
do anything man I'm nothing um Al righty
guys well thank you so much for being
here um make sure to buy yourself a
timey WBY whatever I called that shirt
wly wobbly timey wiy the
doled it and I can't remember what it's
called yeah you gave it the longest
title for a t-shirt ever cuz it should
be it should be I think it you the
wibbly wobbly Tim timey Wy doctor had
Tardis quotes galif speak and I was like
no let's go wibbly
wobbly doctor's lexicon quotes yeah man
it's good makes some super like verbose
Whimsical it's the shirt is bigger on
the inside the name of the shirt is big
but you should see it on the inside how
trippy of a shirt would that be that
would be you put it on and you're like
what so big oh my God I take it off and
it's just like a
small how every time put it on it fits
like an extra large and yet it's a size
small hey this is great for shoplifting
just whoop whoop whoop they should bring
back James Cordon they should bring you
know one place excited to see him one
time people like James Gordon Dr cuz
it's just the right amount it's just the
right pitch he's believable as that
character I never saw James I never saw
like oh I'm watching James Cordon I was
always whoever that guy is yeah I know
slacker not a slack his name again yeah
but he's got the baby and yeah yeah and
the wife who never notices his absence
yes hey man now that we're back maybe
tenant can go see him you know sure
maybe he can surprise and be like hey I
know you spent more time with Matt Smith
than me but hope people everyone who
encounters 14 now is like you're really
boring when we're not traveling you Just
sh don't shut up yeah we know you
traveled oh take me oh you won't take me
you just want to like get fat yeah you
just want to sit here and eat and
comment on the molecular construction of
all the foods that we have on or
Postmates all day you just want to like
break scientifically break down the
regular aspects of our life for the
eenth time they should that would be a
fun episode if like he finally decides
to see him and tenis just like super fat
he's just a busy body and he's fat Don's
like we can't get him out of the house
he won't stop watching the TV yeah you
do like the Classic Bits where he's like
he plays Xbox online in the Tardis all
day yeah oh my God yeah he's got just
like a mess of cables running into the
Tardis door just like a a pathway of
discarded chip wrappers it's hilarious
that's oh it's a
consistently hilarious bit I do not use
that
word you take character make them fat
they play online G it's hilarious yeah
and they get overly invested in it every
time yeah and then he's like you know
bitching out some kid some po kid oh oh
yeah and he's got to have like a kid
companion oh sure he's got like a kid
got a child teenage friend the neighbor
friend yeah who comments on like why
is's the loser but the never notices
he's also a loser for hanging out with
this like older adult
loser but he's a smart nerd smart nerd
child yeah and you finally it's funny
yeah I think it's hilarious it's always
funny it's always funny it's always
hilarious and I hope they do it I want
to see Adam Sandler's Doctor Who it's
GNA be
good is that what he does and that's my
boy no fine fine a hilarious movie way
to go to and I got to do some work okay
my computer I'll stop holding us up here
guys leave a like let us know what you
thought of these specials and what
you're anticipating for the Christmas
special are you a fat gamer are you a
fat
gamer you fat gamer with a beer you
should be working comment below if
you're a fat gamer if you avoided your
problems and your Ambitions now you
leave a hilarious life of gaming being
fat stereotypes and now you
mom mom my Mountain Dew my Mountain Dew
mom get out of my room bit get out of my
room I'm on a campaign Mom it's
hilarious we're doing a raid right now
fat doctor oh yeah fat
doctor fat doctor there should be a
that's the well that's the next Frontier
is we need like a body positive doctor
no going to watch a big that's James
Cordon could be the body positive doctor
no one's going to watch it face no one's
going to watch it I will no one's going
to watch I will and then every episode
is just thinly veiled messaging about
body positivity that's that that's when
these like rage bait YouTube channels
are going to be like can I can I do
thumbnails about this or will I just
look like I'm am I just going to look
like a absolute
bully well cuz
yeah that's where I start to to grow a
conscience of oh maybe I should is fat
dreaming oh damn which I mean you know
people are happy to do it's it's kind of
sucks you know I feel like people in
totally watch an overweight doctor I was
totally kidding I I find that so
relatable I would watch an overweight
doctor and I feel like if anybody gets
mad about it that's when the bubble will
burst cuz people are like you know we
all agree that women don't belong on TV
or black people but like there are fat
people everywhere like who
cares unlike women and and black people
on
[Laughter]
bees all in my tummy Al on
bees oh I got you I got you it's the
it's the Whimsy wibbly wobbly timy wiy
[Music]
diabetes
bees yeah and the atap POS can come back
and save the day oh for sure dogs it's
going to be good people love them they
got name checked here oh damn dude dude
yeah look I'm not going to I'm not going
to say who but there's a CH buddies with
Cosmic wonder and he did a video a few
months ago and he's showing me about how
this other channel that has a few
million Subs where people have been
calling them out for a lot of plagiarism
lately um how they did a video with a
very similar title and their thumbnail
is almost the exact same thing so so
he's being plagiarized can you guys
guess which channel oh God God put it in
the comments oh God no
who's we're going to do a patron of the
day shout out
yay take it away John what name we got
hey let's do the man Chris whama Chris
Wham off yes you know what you're
getting for Christmas this year you're
getting a checkbook to write us more
money for our live streams that's right
our official live stream executive
producer every month you will you don't
have to submit it to streamlabs anymore
we don't have to do a live stream direct
just put it in the tube tube in the
wallet it right to the go right to us I
already filled out all the information
for you all you got to do is sign it
date it and boom right to us yeah
straight into the Wells Fargo account we
go uh no for for Christmas this year you
deserve a good one you should come to LA
and take a tour of the luxurious real
reject Studios yeah it'll be a great two
be like a 20 minute visit yeah we'll
really stretch out the visit you this
poster is from Star Wars this poster is
a Marvel poster this is an office chair
we got for free this is where we keep
the
TV uh no you I hope this Christmas you
are able to enjoy your time with your
fiance cuz he is engaged to a hot
Filipino woman oh look out I know man
that's right widen up that bloodline of
her yes dilute dilute to
Purity and sneak our our our white
ancestry right in there make it happen
man that's right that's how you get a
Greg Elba hey damn you whitewashed
Filipino blood very very conflicting you
know personality traits Italians got
that are in that in between space where
got Olive SK all mean mean I mean I
assume it's some kind of Germanic like
vhu that makes sense yeah well he's very
anti cliche Nazi German and he's back
quite the antithesis to it my friend it
would be a good cover though if you if
you were an H but Chris Wham off you are
a sweetheart and I hope the sweetest
heart I hope I don't know if you believe
in Christmas but if
you believe in all the good that
Christmas is supposed to be about anyway
so I think it cancels out you've been or
Santa that's for sure your Santa and
Jesus all roll th% been our Santa and
our Jesus and our Godzilla all at once
all at once everything everywhere Atomic
breath of gifts is what
we be like oh my God it's go it's a gift
yeah and he's destroyed the
city but it was worth it cuz it wasth
cuz I got a Walmart C we got some
things we got some stuff appreciate you
love you Chris thank you for all you've
been doing for us and for being just the
ultimate support and uh in all
seriousness I hope that you are able to
have a great Christmas with your fiance
yeah and whoever else matters in your
life no one else other than those people
Merry Christmas Merry
[Music]
Christmas